afghanistan wo sich aktuell dramatische
szenen abspielen vor allen dingen vor
den toren kabuls wir zeigen ihnen bilder
die ganz aktuell von dort sind von der
essensausgabe also man sucht dort
verzweifelt an wasser an nahrung zu
gelangen die menschen drängeln sich da
an dieser essensausgabe fast zu tode die
humanitäre krise in kabul um kabel herum
sie spitzt sich immer mehr zu und diese
bilder die uns heute früh erreicht haben
die zeigen warum wir von der hölle von
kabul sprechen und warum die menschen
dort vor allen dingen in den vergangenen
tagen und wochen nur eines wollten
nämlich weg das erklärte ziel der
bundesregierung bei der evakuierungs
mission aus kabul war es sämtliche
ortskräfte zu retten also die menschen
und ihre familien die jahrelang für die
bundeswehr gearbeitet haben und seit dem
einmarsch der taliban jetzt in
lebensgefahr sind die bundeswehr in
afghanistan bereits verlassen die
flieger sind zurück in deutschland aber
wer saß jetzt am ende wirklich in den
rettungs maschinen ja das ist eine
wichtige frage und jetzt gibt es diese
heiklen zahlen die das
bundesinnenministerium in einer internen
schaltkonferenz präsentiert hat unter
den geretteten waren nämlich kaum
ortskräfte also man wollte ortskräfte
evakuieren aber unter den geretteten
waren kaum ortskräfte es waren rund
4.000 afghanen die seit dem 17 augusta
ausgeflogen worden sind und darunter
offiziell heißt es vom
bundesinnenministerium rund 100
ortskräfte dazu kommen dann noch rund
370 familienangehörige davon standen nur
260 menschen am ende auf diesen listen
vom auswärtigen amt also nur ein
bruchteil der ausgeflogenen das muss man
sich noch mal vor augen führen waren
tatsächlich diese ortskräfte und das
heißt natürlich auch über 10.000
ortskräfte und ihre angehörigen sind
noch immer in afghanistan sind dort noch
immer in der sorge in der angst um ihr
leben haben wir stattdessen nach
deutschland ausgeflogen das ist die
große frage besonders bitter ist was
innenminister horst seehofer gestern in
der bams dazu sagte das schauen wir uns
einmal genauer an wer sind also diese
afghan die wir im guten glauben nach
deutschland gebracht haben
das besprechen wir jetzt auch hier mit
claus strunz werden schon darüber
gesprochen klaus was glaubst du wen
haben wir überhaupt die zahlen sind
zerschlagen denn gesagt wir müssen den
menschen die jahrelang 20 jahre lang im
westen wiens deutschland darin
unterstützt haben dort bei diesen
kläglich gescheiterten versuch freiheit
und demokratie ins land zu bringen uns
dann unterstützt haben und die jetzt
versteckt irgendwo fahrrad
verbarrikadiert sitzen und ihr leben
fürchten wenn es nicht geschafft mehr
menschen als die die wir rausgeholt
haben rauszuholen gutes wird hier
begründet mit den chaotischen zuständen
die in den letzten tagen der evakuierung
am flughafen vorgeherrscht haben aber es
bleibt auf der anderen seite auch die
erkenntnis nachdem diese gesamte
afghanistan-mission unsere idee dort die
lebensverhältnisse für frauen für
andersdenkende für homosexuelle zu
verbessern
gescheitert ist ist am ende auch die
evakuierung nicht optimal gelaufen denn
wir haben ganz offensichtlich ich sags
mal so steil die falschen menschen
mitgenommen wir haben ein mandat das ja
auch abgesichert ist dafür ortskräfte
und sagen wir mal politisch
andersdenkende zu evakuieren und haben
jeden mitgenommen der sozusagen gerade
vom flugzeug war und das muss man auch
sagen von den amerikanern dahin
durchgewunken und ist die waren die
gatekeeper die tiefste ja sozusagen an
zwischen hölle und paradies und dann
haben offenbar jeden mitgenommen und
haben gesagt wir checken mal in
deutschland wer dies sind ich glaube das
ist so eine art notwehr der helfer das
muss man auch sagen und wenn jetzt ein
mensch dabei ist oder zwei oder zehn dem
wir das leben retten konnten dann ist
die mission auch schon ein erfolg aber
jetzt kommt die phase der kommunikation
und meine sorge ist dass die politik
wieder den fehler macht wie 215 zu
glauben die menschen die bürger hier
deutschland sind doof jeder weiß doch
dass da jetzt auch schlawiner schlingel
straftäter mit gekommen sind dann muss
man das sagen und muss sagen wir gehen
damit offensiv um und haben ein rezept
dagegen ich befürchte es wird wieder so
raus ich höre jetzt schon vielleicht
sind die in andere länder vielleicht
sind die mit anderen schienen
rausgekommen das sind alles umgehungs
begründungen stadt tacheles zu reden und
es hat doch niemand was gegen tacheles
ich glaube man könnte sich jetzt auch
hinstellen und sagen was wollt ihr
eigentlich klaus sturms ihr typen von
bild live ihr wart doch nicht am
flughafen in kabul da konnte man es nur
so machen dann konnte man nicht die
identität checken da haben wir papieren
glauben müssen und wir wissen da werden
menschen dabei sein die eigentlich nicht
in dieses flugzeug gehören aber wir
werden sie finden und wir werden
entsprechend an das alles höre ich aber
nicht ich höre wir holen ortskräfte
frauen und andersdenkende raus und es
hat alles wunderbar alles reden wollen
wir weiter mit andreas roßkopf fair ist
bundespolizist und bei der gewerkschaft
der polizei zuständig für den ganzen
bundespolizei bezirk schon guten morgen
herr roßkopf claus strunz schön regt
sich gerade auf darüber dass wir so
wenig wissen über die menschen die wir
da aus geflogen haben man wollte
ortskräfte retten jetzt stellt man
plötzlich fest da waren ganz wenig
ortskräfte darüber regt sie das auch
aufregend ist vielleicht falsch
ausgedrückt aber es hat natürlich recht
es ist jetzt die phase genau zu
sondieren wer kommt tatsächlich zu uns
nach deutschland rein das funktioniert
meine ich zumindest bei den flügen noch
sehr gut denn hier haben eine klare
fokussierung der flug kommt an die
passagiere steigen aus und letztendlich
müssen sie dann über festgelegte wege in
die flughäfen hineingehen und so können
wir auch als bundespolizei unsere
kontrollen sehr genau und auch
fokussiert durchführen viel spannender
wird jetzt die frage sein nachdem die
flüge eingestellt sind und die menschen
dann über die landesgrenzen versuchen zu
fuß oder mit fahrzeugen zu flüchten die
dann an unseren landesgrenzen
binnengrenzen ankommen denn da wird es
sehr viel schwieriger zu fokussieren und
auch genau kontrollieren zu können
was glauben sie wen haben wir denn in
den letzten wochen alles nach
deutschland geflogen und wie können wir
das jetzt im nachhinein wie claus strunz
als auch gesagt hat nach überprüfen ja
wie gesagt ich glaube dass wir viele und
die zahlen sprechen dafür hereingeholt
haben hereingelassen haben die keine
tatsächlichen ortskräfte waren aber wir
haben sicherlich auch viele hier jetzt
hereingelassen die von not die
gefürchtet oder fürchten mussten
verfolgt zu werden das allein ist
wichtiger und auch wichtiger schritt
jetzt gilt es durch hilfe der
bundespolizei auch an den grenzen beim
herankommen der menschen zu
kontrollieren wen haben wir vielleicht
jetzt über geholt der bei uns auch gar
nichts verloren hat vielleicht ein
islamist vielleicht ein taliban das gilt
es jetzt zu fokussieren und auch zu
kontrollieren also noch einmal klar
nachgefragt herauskommt sie schließe
nicht aus dass wir uns durch diese
rettungsmission ein zusätzliches
sicherheitsproblem auch hier in
deutschland geschaffen haben
ich schließe natürlich nicht aus weil es
niemand ausschließen kann ich sage nur
eines ganz klar und deutlich bei den
flügen an sich ist es relativ gut
kontrollierbar und nachvollziehbar viel
spannender jetzt die frage der großen
menschen und fachzeitschriften fach
menschen sprechen davon dass weitere bis
zu 500.000 menschen jetzt auf die flucht
gehen können dann wird es natürlich
spannend wie kommen die bei uns rein und
dann ist es auch die spannende frage wie
gehen wir an den landgrenzen damit um um
auch genauso gut kontrollieren und
fokussieren zu können wie bei den flügen
herauskommt vielen herzlichen dank für
ihre einschätzungen
ca
[Musik]